first of all do not adjust your set um
our a wonderful makeup woman mara could
not be here
uh today uh and uh she
she called in and she could not come in
so i have no makeup
right now this is what i truly look like
um no need to panic what do you think
andy
you're conan yes conan oh my god did you
think i was the ghost of conan
i i wasn't sure i thought yeah i thought
maybe it was like some medical exhibit
about the circulatory system
yeah i know i know i don't have makeup
on and everyone on the crew
has been asking me are you okay and
would you like some bone marrow yeah
um but anyway you do have because of
your
iron clad irish genetics
your thousands of years of you do have
like you have a face that like
is timeless you know like you're like
your face could be
like from an old movie you know what i
mean
is this a compliment i mean it is well
yeah i mean if you
choose to take it that way you're a
handsome man thank you but you do have a
you do have like a face that looks like
it could be in a field in 1850
that's the part i don't like the gut
because they had no access to modern
medicine then
you're saying i look like someone who
probably died at the age of 31.
no i'm just saying you look like the
product of a lot of cousin
that's all i'm saying well i thought
that was clear after
28 years of television good god
no i you are a handsome man thank you
man thank you but you're very
irish yeah i am very irish and uh and
and look the makeup makes a difference
it really does
you know it's in it takes a lot of
makeup just to make me look like i'm not
running a fever
but i i think seriously i think you look
good without the makeup okay good well
thank you i like
seeing you natural because it's natural
it's what i see
maybe we should tell mara don't show up
again
you just cost this woman her job hope
you're happy now
well she could come and just kind of
like you know just dab
just as you know i do need some dabs
yeah yeah a few liver spots